it's been a while since we've had a show
about video games like yeah we've been
doing movies for the past however many
weeks like 12 now what's less time
what's the last game we talked about um
maybe of the last of us nope yeah it
might be it might be like it was awhile
ago where we did like a scary one super
long ago I know anyway wow that's Mary
Kish dead air co-host I'm Mike mehar
d-dead our host co-host God Rob handlery
your co-host rob henry this is your what
third time on who's counting I am it's
your third time okay no yeah we figure
we get back to talking about games for a
little while there's nothing immediately
pressing in terms of releases and
everything I know like a lot of our
audience comes here for movie
discussions and whatnot we did Halloween
the 28 days later probably do I was
looking on the calendar for when the
next friday the 13th is it's not until
like end of January so we might just
have to do that before an actual friday
the 13th rolls around but then we're
gonna be screwed on that Friday the 13th
but that's also the week res evil 7
releases which kind of brings me back uh
way I want to talk about games like the
upcoming horror games are most excited
about whether they're coming out really
soon or just like don't even have a
release date which a lot of those that's
the case with a lot of them uh Mary you
made this list cuz you did like a
feature video recently right during
Halloween yeah I did I did like um I try
to do this every year around October
where I talk about like the best
upcoming horror games to come and then
within like of course as soon as I
release it then there's a new trailer
for something amazing or something that
I missed that I'm like why didn't I put
that in like I put routine and last year
but this year they didn't have an
updated trailer so I didn't put them in
and then with students they released it
routine had a new trailer it looks
really good which is the one where
you're like in space but there's
definitely something else going on in
space and space and you're gonna die in
space yeah Rob you don't play a ton of
horny as I brought you on just cuz i
don't know why did i bring you on dude I
don't know but no you've been playing I
am more lately right like between
residue seven the outlast
demo just like kind of dabbling yeah I
mean at the end the day I I'm a
scaredy-cat I'm like you know may it be
movies or games like I can get scared
easy and I think that's what like you
know scares me from playing them this
sometimes it's like just investment like
I don't know being a loner in a room at
one am playing a game like I'm not gonna
go to bed rest the night and sometimes I
don't want to do that um but I get a
kick out of like watching trailers
watching you guys play them like a
jump-scare is it's exhilarating but yeah
so I watched all the trailers that we
met you know we may be talking about as
far as games and routine was like
definitely like top two um that one
looked real cool as far as some of the
mechanics introduced like for one thing
I think it was really standout ish was
that it seemed like they were like
different types of creatures that are
chasing you not just you know a nice
trope of games right is one alien alien
monster robot chasing you in tune yeah
this one looked like what was like a
robot and then like a sewage crawlin
alien uh so it feels like you know
you're you're consistently like changing
how you play that game which is nice
like different you know methods of
escaping but the thing that was really
cool to me was the gun that the person
was using it was like an infrared weapon
that I look like it was able to stun
someone however the frame rate of it was
really slow and if you noticed and that
was cool to me that it's useful for of
course seeing in the dark but just like
having that slow frame rate looking
through the viewfinder of it like made
it more frustrating right like it
because it's you get started harder to
judge speed of whatever following you
like it was just like a cool little
gimmick I thought yeah just you know to
build off the excitement and the
scariness of it you're talking about a
like a persistent enemy chasing you kind
of and this he said my it's a robot I
haven't seen all the trailers I saw the
release date trailer because they said
there were aiming for a late 2016 but
they said they were releasing too close
to steam Christmas cells they being
lunar software the developer um I don't
think they have yeah they don't have a
few I don't have an actual release date
yet but yeah it reminded me of Mary just
finished reading able to for the first
time on resin Knievel this let's play
series her an idea of all the the game's
plug go check it out on youtube gamespot
subscribe but yeah we're coming up on
nemesis now resin evil 3 nemesis and
that was probably exampled before that
but the earliest one I can remember is
like a persistent threat the Nemesis
itself is the thing chasing youth like
unscripted throughout the game so if you
take too long in one area or just
randomly to Buster wall like the
kool-aid man kind of and then also I
think I mentioned this on the podcast
for Bioshock 2 when it was in
development Jordan Thomas the lead
designer on it a tattoo came of rain at
the time they wanted the big sister to
be this persistent threat like that but
then they made they took the big sister
who was one enemy and started scripting
the encounters because there were
several big sister to think or at least
it was the same one that you're seeing a
few times throughout it but it was
scripted it wasn't this persistent
threat then alien isolation is another
one but that sounds cool about routine
because you want to stop and kind of
explore the space and figure out what's
going on you know ideally if this is how
the game is made but at the same time
having that like nagging in the back of
your head that this robot is kind of
hunting you yeah space is like the
ultimate place for a horror game because
much like in this is often in cinema
they put you in a space where you
actually can't escape you can't go
anywhere there's nothing you can really
do about the situation besides
continuously try to either remove the
thing that's trying to kill you or or
just continue to run and hide but
there's actually no relief there's no
way to escape it because you are stuck
you know on the ship and there's just
nowhere to go and that in itself is so
terrifying so routines environment alone
leaves itself for something that's just
going to scare you and then in addition
they've just done a really good job of
maintaining the mystery of what it is
that's actually out to get you there's
not a lot of story yet and sometimes
that makes people nervous like you know
how do I even know it's good you haven't
told me enough but you know I really
believe like there's there's something
really good there that I'm seeing in the
trailers I really love what they've done
with their marketing so far I'm very
excited to see what
they show next so routine is super on my
radar now and I'm just kind of hoping I
don't see anything more I don't want to
be spoiled for anything else I just want
to play it when it comes out now sorry
it as a March 2017 according to the
release date trailer from the other day
that's what I want mm-hmm could you
judge by that I mean all I saw was this
one trailer have they stated that
elsewhere that that is the goal of the
game is that you are consistently being
chased there aren't any hadn't said
anything okay I thought maybe that was
like no I mean I think that that's like
the overarching fear right is that you
don't really know what's going on so
you're just going to be consistently
hunted and much like most games that
take place in space like alien isolation
right you're you're never really free
it's you're always gonna have this
looming presence because there's nowhere
else to go so it would it seems likely
but no they've been really really good
about kind of not letting you know about
all the threats that are that are out
there yeah and that's it reminds me of
Tacoma the floor by companies next game
I've the developer behind gone home but
that is unless of a horror game for what
it seems that's more just the you know
like the term now that I know a lot of
people don't like is walking simulator
but it's like a narrative driven
environmental storytelling yeah it has a
dark side to it their trailers have
shown there's obviously something wrong
that's not that's going on on that space
station but I don't think it's going to
have the the horror esque feel to it I
would say like maybe Selma might be a
good comparison como is all about like
science fiction you know there's
something out there what happened all
these people everybody's dead you're
kind of unraveling the story through
terminals and log entries and stuff like
that yeah and there's also like no HUD
no health bars or points or anything or
full body awareness whatever that means
I wonder what that means you wear a full
suit and whatever you feel in the game
you feel in real life man that one
moment in that trailer uh on the end
where he's climbing up the ladder it's
chasing him yoo hoo hoo got that like
patter of whatever legs had had like as
you're climbing the ladder yeah screw
that that is so hard like my steps are
effective that was so effective what was
that uh the short lights out lights out
your the shore
inspire them we lights out that in the
hallway when she turns lights are you
here like bubble it's scare the [ __ ] out
of me I was driving hate the rise of
pace right like yeah you know it meant
some of it yeah here at getting closer
without knowing what it is right um
that's yeah so that's March that's right
around damn so we saw we played out last
two for the first time in March apexi
Sumerian Boston uh-huh that I'm really
excited for that game you played the
newest demo right Rob I'm sorry which
one Oh at last oh yeah you streamed up
yeah I did stream in rod and barrels it
was gonna be this year they delay that
2017 there have like a window yet but
yeah item in cornfields and in gross
water and in lockers you got that camera
they brought back the famous camera
mechanic with dead batteries yeah it's
so good it's got like a really nice
premise to it as well where it's like
now you're in a village and there's just
like crazy religious villagers
everywhere and you got to hide from them
they did such a good job with the first
one but the first one was a surprise
nobody knew it was going to be that good
it was so good so it's like now people's
expectations are risen so there's a lot
of pressure on them to rise the occasion
and make an even better game now people
know what to expect from out last game
so what what else are they going to
throw at us if they if the full game
carries their own with the demo hinted
at the fact that they're kind of going
for these different types of horror
throughout the game because the demo
itself was like yeah poltergeist in that
school locker is opening closing
freaking out when you're hiding from
this invisible thing that's just [ __ ]
with you uh there's a sense of like like
you said in the village with these
crazed villagers that are chasing you
and of course they get that game is like
best mechanic is when you're running and
you could do to look behind button you
see people chasing you it's not just
jump scares it's that tension of being
chased like I'm when I was younger I
used to run up my basement stairs and
always think someone's behind me classic
or when I used to get out of bed in the
middle of the night I would have to jump
like from my bed so nothing could grab
me from under my bed right I mean of
course now I just like I have this pitch
for cash of Honor I have a news day I
just like unload a clip on their ya raba
was that neighbor see that parkour
zombie game that i was thinking of that
as well you remember green light dying
light when you did the look behind
mechanic and they would be slow mo and
so there was like these
ort of like super infected zombies slow
motion like about to kill you would you
turn around and go there you go because
you knew they were coming I think that
had like a cool down or like stammen
effect to it so like you couldn't just
like spam it but yeah that'd be the case
of like you know you run around at night
and those uh volatiles or just like
chasing you and you just you just look
behind you and you're like how many are
actually following me a tour sick is
this is sort of chasin okay the [ __ ] ton
of them yeah yeah less 2 i'm really
excited for that when i got too late i
was i was disappointed but I hope you
know obviously they're taking the time
to just polish it and whatnot I'd rather
be delayed and it's good I have really
high expectations for this one yeah I
don't think it's a bad indicator oh I
just be like me good yeah I the only
thing is i would i would hope that there
are um I don't know this is kind of how
I feel about games or you're walking
around morgue exploration the demo was
fairly linear yeah i would say except
for yeah i mean like it's certain parts
are they open up I word that the
cornfield right right you're kind of
asked to do that but um I like the idea
of the first one right where it's just a
huge mansion or hospital I felt like you
could really explore in the hospital
yeah and more seamlessly introduced like
levels or like goals in each level like
I don't know how that's the first one
that well but I remember there at least
like you know the basement level worth
at that huge walking mm-hmm there's a
lack of a man is chasing you uh those
were regulated right between yeah I was
almost I mean if you played gone home is
kind of like that or it was almost like
a Metroid like a metroid prime is kind
of item gated or like there are certain
triggers that would let you go into
another area so you couldn't freely
explore the whole thing right away but
there was definitely room to kind of
wander around but yeah cuz I I went down
the stairs and saw the basement and I
heard the water down there I heard
something we've really not [ __ ] going
down there until I have to I go back
upstairs I think you get a key down
there you need to turn the power on and
then you see a note saying break her in
the basement got what somebody's replace
the fuser like [ __ ] then you're just say
it was such a good way to foreshadow
there's nothing that made me go check
the basement out before I went down
there but it just worked out really well
I'm curious so res evil 7 is january
twenty fourth and that's the game I'm
really excited for we've talked about a
lot we had Tim Terry on who you know
like working on the on the title is in
terms of social media and brand
management goes and I mean Mary like you
and I you're even playing through a few
the resin tables for the first time I've
loved them for my whole life I really
can't wait for seven it seems like a
pretty drastic departure I mean you had
the first three games which were
survival-horror fixed camera angles you
know puzzle oriented then he had four
five six progressively more action in
each one third person shooter adventure
game and now you have to wonder if this
is like kicking off because of the rise
in indie horror that was first person
immersion and what not that kind of saw
a huge rise when resident evil and
silent hills were not doing well so like
the big triple a horror series kind of
had their darker years in a bad way and
then indie horror just made a comeback
with like you know amnesia the dark
descent or anything like that and that's
why I'm curiously what resin people has
learned from those games and what it's
doing in terms of franchise but yeah
it's January 24th we have seen a little
more of the action side of things terms
of weapons and inventory management
because at first it was just you know
that that out last to kind of
first-person narrative driven emotions
they were going for but now it's pretty
cool the structure we know more about
the structure the game it's you come
across these videotapes or these audio
logs and you the flashbacks themselves
instead of audio logs you go play the
flashbacks as these random like short
stories so resonable 7 itself is this
frame story containing the smaller short
stories of random people may be
connected to the plot maybe just
tangential maybe they have nothing to do
the game and I'm really excited to see
how that plays out and then how
inventory management these puzzles work
more in a first-person setting so that's
coming out before outlast to now yeah
it's crazy like how that's swapped
around and becomes something that we
should really be talking about and
thinking about much sooner they've done
so much to get us thinking not just
switching it to first person but they've
also added VR I mean a lot of us did
these these demos in VR it's crazy like
this is the first red
evil VR it's such a wild wild switch up
but resident evil is known for switching
it up for better and for worse for both
and so I think it's important to
understand that the resident evil series
has constantly pushed the bar you've
never seen a resident evil that just
does the exact same thing over and over
and over again they're always trying
something new so we can't really
determine whether or not yet you know
this is this is a great thing but it is
definitely definitely interesting and
there's there's so much that they're
doing with it right like they're doing
the new sneak the hide and sneak
mechanics that's like basically we're
like someone's chasing you and you're
meant to hide that's very I think it's
quite inspired by amnesia right it's
you're not you have nothing to defend
yourself with this is a huge break away
from like a lot of the other games where
you always have like some kind of weapon
or something to defend yourself the demo
I play the lantern demo you can't defend
yourself you are literally hiding behind
boxes and squeezing in between walls and
looking for things under floorboards you
can't defend yourself like that's mad so
they've they really gone beyond anything
I've ever seen in a resident evil before
and it seems like a nice way to change
up like the main story I would how i
imagining it is like main narrative is
like you with weapons being able to like
defend yourself but it seems like or
what i would hope out of those
videotapes is to see like a different
type of system in place that is making
you more vulnerable the gameplay motif
yeah like a like a chase like that or
like maybe you only have you know they
cut off your arm and you have a knife
hand and I don't know slip on here even
in 16 for a leg yes is sick that'd be
good well it was that in the grindhouse
yes thanks to know or Bayonetta yeah
anyways um but yeah you know I mean like
you just people like change it up
without dieter or like deterring from
like the actual narrative like it seems
like a really cool way to like you know
I guess you could almost call them like
moments of like like down time or like
or like you know just having a very
dynamic game in general being able to
change it up sounds like I could make
the pacing like do wonders for the
pacing yeah I'm also as much as I like
VR I haven't really been excited for a
VR game until
now because this whole game is going to
be in VR on p sv r which is really
exciting it's optional right like you
thought yeah no no you can just play it
on ps4 or xbox one and pc but i will
probably play through it and then play
through it again in VR because of the
horror games I played on PS VR or oculus
or gear no not care i'm sorry the HTC
vive i haven't played anything that like
blew me away and it sounds like Capcom's
paying a lot of attention to VR with us
and I really want to play in that
because I did you play the lantern demo
in VR right yeah it really works like
yeah like well uh sit down gains the VR
are generally much safer for me like
compared to like actually walking around
with the virus me that like those can
exhaust your brain sometimes unless
we're done really well like I've played
a few of them on the vibe but this was
like safe it felt you know I I could I
could comfortably take it off after like
20 minutes Amelia I could see myself
playing longer forms of this and that is
worth looking at and in yeah that was
probably the best experience i had with
like a like a horror scary game using VR
and it's funny enough is we're talking
about these games a bunch of these and
once i really liked and i'll talk about
the one later i'm sure we'll get to but
I was like generally was like looking to
see if it was gonna be in VR yeah
sometimes you see that game you're like
this would be really cool you know like
a PT or something like that like this
could work yeah we uh I can't talk too
much about it but in like a couple weeks
or we'll have an entire episode devoted
more to resonable 7 we have a lot more
residue seven coverage coming behind the
scenes stuff to which I'm pretty excited
about is a life-time resonable fan but
yeah stick around for that yeah we you
mentioned I mean way to mention outlast
whereas equals seven there's another
game from tiny bill games i did
speedrunners um it's in this game hello
neighbor do you guys check that out yeah
I put that in the video it's so
interesting the trailer is very weird
very weird that looks frickin awesome it
was fun yeah of all them in the lot it
made it made me the most intrigued
apparently because they're boasting the
AI right learns so if you're constantly
like throwing a tomato at the window
let's
say to get him out of the house you can
get back in it's not going to work after
like a couple tries he's learned that
that's what you're doing to get him out
of the house and he's becoming attuned
to it so it's supposed to be adaptive AI
have the primary we didn't really okay
yeah you are dude in a really nice
neighborhood its stylized like kind of
like a Pixar cartoon almost that's
pushing it but it's like a nice colorful
whimsical style and there's something
wrong with your neighbor and he's doing
something really weird and you don't
know what's going on with him but he's
definitely messed up and his basement
has locks on it and you want to know
what's in his basement now the brief
trailer that I saw which is not spoilery
so don't worry about it but it's
basically like I would watch the first
trailer and nothing else I would not
watch the second row they released ten
minutes of demo it was too much right
the trailer is basically setting up that
this neighbor is doing something weird
and you're trying to investigate but you
don't want to get caught so you're doing
stuff like throwing the tomato at his
window to get them out to clean it then
you run inside you gotta try to get to
the basement but it's locked so you got
to find like a hammer so you can get
like a key so you can pry off the boards
but if he catches you and does towards
the end of the trailer um it ends with
you being buried so or you look yeah
whatever it is it look like you're being
yeah I guess you were being beard you're
being killed so it's like he's got
something in there that's worth killing
over but you don't know what it is and
that's it and i really recommend to not
see there was a 10 minute demo that
showed like some more stuff but i think
that's all you need and much like a
horror movie I've like said this to you
Mike all the time they always show too
much I can't stand it don't show me just
show me the premise I love the premise
and I don't I don't think anyone should
see much more than that I hope the
adaptive AI is as cool as it sounds yeah
the only thing and it's not even there
are so many different things you do in
the game which he can learn from so it's
not just like you throw a tomato at the
window it's like you you know
distracting him with the television or
turning on an alarm in the other room
like you can't how I Maja's you can't go
to like you're basically the game is
making you consistently uncomfortable
and unfamiliar with like how you should
plan your attack right like cuz I feel
like what could come off as like a
trial-and-error game where it's like
okay
I got this far me do the exact same
thing and get you know from let me get
to this door quicker and remove the
nails from the board uh in order to get
in that's just not going to work you're
completely like how I imagined it is
like in the moment you're panicking
you're finding a new way to like handle
this guy distract him yeah I think it's
trying to make you it's forcing you to
come up with things on the fly right
both with how to get out of there when
he finds you because when he does see
you the music is like don't don't don't
don't don't do any like comes at you
like to try to get you do you like jump
out of freaking window or like do
something to get away from him but it's
pretty wild like if even if he like does
get really close to you it's about
deciding on the fly which room you're
gonna go into and how you're going to
throw something in another room so it
gets distracting I think it's meant to
make you do things in the moment and not
plan ahead just like you're saying Rob
like it's not it's not meant for you to
have a game plan it's right it's just I
think it's it looks pretty good I hope
it is what it appears to be no it is in
there's builds people can play I can
tell you that right now yeah there's one
on the site pre-alpha early access it
reminds me we talked about don't breathe
the movie recently and that was like the
same thing the basement was locked they
snuck into someone's house the guy in
hello neighbor the game is not blind but
it also reminds me which don't breathe
reminded me of this is a deep cut I hear
some Matilda when she gets it under the
table Miss Trunchbull house and has to
avoid her that's what I mine so much
like that yeah like that in your the
home invader it's weird because I don't
like movies like The Strangers like home
invasion I know a lot of people like Tim
Terry who's come on here my roommate in
divorce Capcom they people who have seen
like every horror movie the one thing
that still gets them is home invasion
just because you don't you don't feel
there's no way you can remove yourself
from it once you go home after and like
it that's your last like fortress or
whatever yeah do you remember the one
with the deaf mute girl yeah and there's
a guy who's like trying to invade her
home and he's like he's doing it over
time yeah wait till we talked about I
don't know why I forget the name is I'm
gonna look it up older movie ya know you
can like I did suck on netflix or
something hush hush hush yeah we
we talk about it no it's yeah it sounds
like just a relative me it kind of
reminds me of that to where you're like
I he's just a crazy guy trying to get
her house but she's got to find ways
she's effing my dad even though she's
deaf and mute to like sense him and like
stop him from getting in the house aw so
good yeah tonight show a lot like her
like kind of POV of like what she has to
rely on nuts like not POV but yeah
essentially yeah audio and vibration
vibrations and say hey um are like yeah
it comes down to that in the end um but
yeah it's cool because this takes that
you're the home invader but you don't
feel safe so the person in the house is
the one with the power which is not the
usual paradigm there there's one big in
that trailer to that like really maybe
just like freaked out inside and i would
actually really i want to see how this
game is streamed and how people like
watch it live because i think it could
actually be eight much of an like the
guy was playing you kind of were like
you wanted to punch your screen because
he was stalling and taking like a while
wheezing is he still chasing me like
just go you yeah and he turns around and
it's a door this is like we're the the
person who the neighbor who owns a house
is like almost like comical but it still
works returns and it's a locked door
with a lock and then on the right is
like five different keys so he says he's
going try every game it's like what a
jerk you know it's it's like it's staged
but in that respect um you know you
think you have time and then you get to
these roadblocks and you don't you got
to get each nail out of the board and
that's what's scary right is knowing
that he is behind you in a second he's
gonna grab you but you still got these
nails at the part like it's that that
total suspension tension that is like
wildly attractive to me like I love that
stuff yeah from a unique gameplay
perspective that game is really
appealing I actually between that and
killing floor 2 which we want to talk
about on this episode they're both in
early access so I kind of my try both
those out maybe we have an extra life
stream come out maybe I don't know yeah
something but that we don't yet see
enough of in horror is emergent gameplay
or basically like when situational
things happen because of the player you
see a lot of what we're always talk
about
earlier where it's like set things that
have been designed it's a set path and
when you walk this way something's going
to jump scare you and the guy will come
out at this particular time but like
emergent gameplay is not used enough in
horror or a way to create a situation in
which you can approach in many many many
different ways and how you choose to do
that will completely change the way the
AI vai is impacted or the world itself
and the outcome I think that that is
that's just something we don't see
enough of it possibly was like a
technological limitation until now so
very high hopes for that to see if like
the AI is smart and as interesting as I
hope it is yeah absolutely and that's
what I probably poorly said about
outlast where you when you feel like you
are responsible for being caught or
killed or whatever it is that is like
prime [ __ ] to me in a game right like
you are at fault like whatever you did
you did wrong you're not surrendering
yourself to the script yeah you're you
have some agency which means not only
can you escape if you're good enough
means you have the potential [ __ ] up and
it's it's almost the equivalent to like
yeah like jump scares and movies you
know like okay yeah you got me yes it's
so easy sometimes to do a jump scare
yeah yeah uh yeah absolutely um another
one I want to talk about quick was a
system shock remastered weird system
shock it's weird Dishonored 2 as we
speak just released today while we're
recording this uh sorry tomorrow at the
time of this recording November 11th
dishonor two releases and if you look
back through bioshock dishonored the
first game you know like deus ex all
these games kind of stem from like the
system shock the origin systems days
origin systems a lot of people went from
there like sorry Looking Glass
technologies a lot of people took went
from looking glass in Cambridge
Massachusetts all those years ago ken
Levine started on system shock to people
like Doug Church who's been at valve now
for a number of years war inspector
started it or like looking glass in
origin I this is the kind of game that
started off that whole vein of narrative
first-person shooters or kind of between
dishonor to bioshock this it was also
one of the first games and a system
shock was one of the first games too
use environmental storytelling like
audio logs and messages and kind of that
was at the time that was huge it's also
probably I think one of the first that
had such a crazy AI villain for for like
the head villain in a video game like I
always wondered if like System Shock was
things that inspired portal or were like
basically when it was yeah something
that's not human that is AI that's
adaptable slowly saying more and more
uncomfortable things I getting showed
you know show Dan likes kind of starts
out just saying like you know what is it
like to like feel or what is it like to
you know think and then it starts like
question humanity it starts getting like
what is it like you know what would it
be like to just not to just be drained
of your skin they all would like to be a
bag of skin with no blood in it you're
just like well now I'm uncomfortable
Sheridan like you've gone too far I mean
it's like a pretty slow build of a
curious being that seems to get angry
over time it's a really well done a bad
guy essentially yeah it's uh the
original system shock is kind of hard to
play now with a very cluttered HUD
controls are not that great no John Luke
was capturing and do it video stuff with
the remaster the remaster comes out in
December I believe I and we'll talk
about that now because again yeah like
you said it is there are horror elements
to it but it's also just how it tells
its story in terms of audio logs me out
last does that now res evil 7 does like
so many horror games have taken that
gameplay conceit and kind of like
exploded it to tell a story and now it's
how many years at 22 years after
assistant job release and they're doing
the remaster now so I'm excited to play
that if not just because I played the
original one I did this like i did a
freelance feature on looking blessed 2d
doesn't where all the developers ended
up and so I played System Shock it was
tough to go back to but I mean if you
played like mankind divided this year if
you play dishonored to the Bioshock
collection beef few years ago those are
all just pretty much spiritual
successors to the system shock and those
kind of games what do you anticipate for
the remaster like what do you think will
come out of it they're updating the
controls they are making the bit more a
little more accessible for people who
never play
it which I'm looking forward to because
again that's one of the instances where
like if you want the original experience
you can but like the original fallouts
if you want to do that the controls just
kind of it's a battle i would recommend
if you feel like playing in the next
month i would wait for this shock
remastered for sure probably be worth it
night dive Studios is doing the remaster
so yeah I'm looking forward to that for
sure that's before like holidays hit or
I think it is they said december two
thousand oh I'm sorry December 2017 this
way off yeah either way so that's next
year but still you can't play it there
was a demo was there not I know I know
John Luke was capturing it so yeah
definitely yeah cool um yeah we also
have for another soon-to-be-released
game killing floor 2 like killing for if
you're a fan of left 4 dead won't be too
foreign to you it's just like a wave
base kind of survival game with four
player co-op we played the marriage you
play the early access build yet you know
I haven't had a chance to play it in
fact I actually wasn't into killing
floor one not because I didn't have not
cuz I didn't like I just have time but
you know who was was Andy bow bow and
that dude loved killing floor needs to
always talk to me about it and how much
he just thought were like greatest game
because you're just constantly shooting
waves and waves of people and it's just
like it's got the impact II feel of like
a traditional multiplayer shooter but
it's not about that but it gives you the
same satisfaction that you would if you
were to play like um like a battlefield
type game where like the guns are really
well done and really really well-made
they make you feel really good when you
use them but it's about horror and it's
about just a bunch of horrible gross
things comin atcha so it kind of
combines everything that I like it's
also multi players that kind of gives me
that like left for dead vibe that I want
so I mean I'm in I just haven't had a
chance i actually I'm quite embarrassed
I think we should I think we should all
be playing it and kind of do like a
stream of it I think we should be doing
like a multiplayer around with it yeah
it's on pc ps4 coming out soon it
doesn't i mean i'm sure it's technically
horror but uh I don't know it didn't
seem like too scary its horror in the
same way that like left for dead is yeah
fighting it's not it's
you're not fighting it's not as much
about the horrors is about the cert
co-op survival this is kind of the
mindless idea yes mowing down people
yeah um and in that so yeah that
releases a I think next Friday on steam
so again at the time this recording is
like a week in a week but we do it's in
early access right now and I know we
have we're gonna be playing on ps4
pretty soon in the office I don't know
if we'll try to do a stream or something
but yeah I'm really looking forward to
it because there are different like
arenas you could fight in different
people you can play as and everything is
it I have to make the comparison because
I don't know much about killing floor at
all is it it's what's reminisce until i
got like a nazi zombies or zombies
called your shirt I think yeah we're
like you go for long stretches like some
of my favorite favorite memories and
where those games get real tense is when
you've put in like an hour and a half
right you're trying to get to like you
know the highest level you can and then
you're just cornered it's just like your
get overrun and then that's where the
panic really pumps in like through a
general adrenaline and so like that like
is just the same kind of basis is that
is there any ending to like these waves
or like how the game operates on no it's
sure it's honestly in terms of like the
structure of its it meets up to six
players so that's one more than horde
but horde from Gears of War you get a
boss every like 10 waves right this is
structured similarly you get a like a
random kind of boss character after you
kill a certain out of thick homesteads
in this zombies but yeah you get this
boss fight and there again it's just
like Gears of War essentially kind of
looking like gears were for kind of you
know looking at it and that released
just a month ago looks like they took
stuff from the first killing floor in
2009 because yeah there's a blast wave
everyone so i left you kill like
increasing amount of zombies and
everything and that's what the wouldn't
actually challenged you but yeah you can
play up to six people so that itself is
kind of cool because it's not just like
for like left for dead or the you know
like yours war does five again and horde
but yeah killing floor 2 is between the
coop aspects but i really like co-op
games come up focus games and the actual
just like horror elements of it i'm
looking forward to playing that and that
yeah that's like next week so that would
cool looking for deplane that and then
in terms of coop in like a symmetrical
way we talk about dead by daily a lot
and
I have an update with that they have
certain serial killers they've
introduced yeah they had a did by
daylight had the halloween special right
where they added michael myers and i
think they're gonna continue to add more
we always thought that one of them was
practically Jason anyway because he was
just kind of like this creepy psycho
killer that had like a machete but he
wasn't the same but it now looks like
they're able to legally get those people
but I'm really interested in the actual
way to play Friday the 13th orem yeah
Jason Voorhees which would be the Friday
the 13th game which looks so rad you are
asymmetrical 4v1 you're either one of
the four camp counselors trying to
survive or you are Jason himself and I
love for v1 we had these like long
conversations last year about
asymmetrical games because there was
just so many coming out from like golf
crawl and evolve and how good they are
because there's something really
wonderful about the person with the
power being a human being and not being
AI right so it's just like giving that
power to a person and how much that
makes the gameplay way more fascinating
and way more interesting in this one
Jason is like basically stalking these
camp counselors and brutally massacring
them i really mean it's brutal like he's
like smashing their pics is into fires
and like teeth Oh launching off the
board that cabin lush eddying them in
hacking them in many pieces it's wildly
brutal which i think is satisfies a lot
of people who are fans of that genre but
for people who may be like don't care
about friday 13th or even into like that
kind of horror element of it go arounds
yeah they're gonna still love when you
get into a symmetrical multiplayer like
you're talking about really interesting
gameplay and say what you will evolve
was [ __ ] interesting like it was so
cool to have one v 4 gameplay I loved it
I absolutely thought it was so
fascinating i wish we could do that more
i think uh this seems like an easier
game maybe to balance simply because
like it's such a pure good and evil type
situation or i would say you know if
you're a camp counselor like probably
gonna die and if everyone dies that's
cool that's the horror movie you know I
mean opposed to like evolver it's like
that's tough as hell
right like how do you balance that game
and you know as we were playing that
game I think people could could and
would complain about like all it's on
balance like molesters 20 p what is that
this seems just like the joy of it seems
prime it seems like it seems like a safe
asymmetrical game to make ya this fine I
can't wait for it it's a spring
sometimes spring next year ps4 xbox one
pc and i'm really looking for that
because dead by daylight had the same
idea and the same kind of conceits and i
really liked that game I still played
every once in a while with friends but
this one looks little more polished just
which i think is what debt by daily
needs it and in a lot of ways dead by
daylight kind of you know piggybacked
off of fri the 13th announcement which a
lot of smaller studios will do like
they're just game burst fire a couple
few months ago that's it since been
polled because not enough people played
it but they at once rainbow six siege
was announced they kind of made it
quickly and then released it before it
got released so i think that's what that
by daylight did a little bit i don't
know that's just what it seemed like
they're kind of capitalizing the trend
but yeah i'm looking forward to fri the
13th more just because a i want to
polish the asymmetrical horror game
which is what this you know looks like
it's gonna bring about so it look like
Jason started it look like Jason could
like I see movement in like he had
senses right in the game just like
having seen the trailer like I haven't
seen much of this game but it it looked
like when you could crawl under a bed
and what like hold your breath like what
do you know like anything about what you
do as the camp no I mean in the trailers
I saw I saw just the massacre trailer
which is just Jason killing everyone
okay so I haven't seen too much of the
mechanics I do think a lot of people
have been comparing it to dead by
daylight which is the one where you
could like hear their movement so if
they [ __ ] up like you can see their
outline and go chase them and I would
not be surprised if this takes a lot of
those elements but what I don't know is
you know how the camp counselors survive
is it by killing Jason who is it by
escaping like dead bite he's had to
survive at night I don't know if yeah
he'll Jason from what I've read I mean
is it like baby life's got a bang if
it's like realize you can't live yeah
yes you know sex is what gets them
killed yeah movie well it to directly
thank you any about camp counselors I'm
saying like round two like they had
round one in like like the end
of the movies like we I get to run to I
know which council you'll be you'll be
the ones look hey guys who wants to bang
first it's me I brought and then I got a
call about two beers for everyone and
then I get kicked out I'm like oh this
sucks I go take a piss then I'm then you
get killed again and then like yeah you
you're peeing and then all of a sudden
the moonlight sheds more light and
you're peeing on Jason's face yeah and
it goes back how are your breath stinks
what is your spine and half your last
words you're just like it's so uncool
nothing really [ __ ] just sure how had
him that you know this camp gnarly
anyway Allison Road want to talk about
we talked about a lot before it's just
essentially people are seeing as the
their last chance at having my apt yeah
I got cancelled earlier this summer and
then it revived the creators like no
we're still working on it we're gonna
kind of revive it they don't they're not
they don't the same publisher anymore
but yeah that's like a takes place in a
suburban setting in a house something
went wrong with the family that lived
there it essentially we've talked about
PC PT a lot we talked about Allison
wrote here now when it got revived again
but yeah that's again no release date or
anything it was a no talking about some
like reservations with it though because
they've had so many like happening oh no
it's cancelled like oh no what's
happening and now I'm like yeah I don't
like if I my Stoke level is as high as
it used to because I'm afraid that it's
gonna get cancelled again some of my
spirits aren't as high as they used to
because I won't get let down yeah yeah
it looks really PT yeah oh yeah even as
far as like I he lifts up a seems to be
a lot more interaction right compared to
PT and PTT was a super demo but there
was one bit where he lifts up the like a
picture and looks behind and there's
writing on it and it says something like
dad was such a drag which is a total
line straight from PT yeah like through
the radio you know any me like dad was
such drag first time ever that was like
oh wow this is beauty part to like yeah
uh they looked cool look [ __ ] scary
like certain parts right when he's
mending yeah I skimmed through it
because it was pretty long but there's
one Rosie where he's in the closet
it's like lights are flickering out when
he hears voices in this claustrophobic
setting it's like someone is in the like
you know behind like like the clothes
that's where you're imagining some was
gonna pop out that was freshman you know
what's like stereo headset on like that
would do a number on my left or right I
mean that's the tough thing with this
game with any horror game really I
talked to horror developers every once
in a while and they're saying you know
like even movie directors who are making
horror movies they don't go all the way
with how much they could scare you
because no one would watch the movie and
no one would be able to take it there
are there are directors that do that but
those are the movies you see less and
those are like the ones you have to like
stream online because you watch it once
and you're like this isn't enjoyable at
all similarly with games even more so
because the agency in the interaction
interactivity you can't go all the way
to 10 with your scared no one's going to
play your game it's gonna be too hard to
play especially with VR now VR the
threshold is so much lower for people
like what they can take it that's why
kind of have to I don't know like I'm
always fascinated with the design
process with horror games because you
really have to rein yourself in like I'm
sure like if we had ideas for game we
could think of like the scariest thing
possible but it wouldn't necessarily
make it a good game like reading evil 7
they have to balance how fun the game is
with you know how much they scare you
and everything and how much is actually
creeping you out so Allison road yeah I
have reservations as well kind of
curious see what that small team can do
that's working on it now yeah III think
it it's kind of I don't think it's
unfair because it's clearly going for a
PT silent Hills kind of vibe but at a
certain point I'm trying not to compare
it too much to it because I feeling was
gonna it's gonna be a letdown gonna be
disappointed but that's just me being
cynical when it comes to this game
vertical we want to mention a couple
last-minute ones agony we saw that long
trailer for it yeah monik hellscape it
looks really not so it looks like you're
in the body of something like it's just
wild like all the walls are alive and
breathing and they look like they're the
internal organs of something large but
then there's jail cells within this body
that also contain like horrible
tormented souls I think the whole thing
is about Hell I mean if you ask me it
just seems like it's Dante's Inferno
you're just like in a forever hell and
everybody is being tortured forever
around you
and even though it was so cool it is
early on so we should like be reasonable
here I just don't know what I'm doing
yeah it was like a walking tour of hell
and god damn it was scary it was really
creepy and like you know it's hard to
watch sometimes you just like watching
all these like horribly upset people
like being tortured but I just don't
know what I'm doing it without the
gameplay it's really hard for me to make
any kind of statement on whether or not
I'm gonna like it yeah I think visually
it was pretty freakin nutty uh but I
totally agree as far as that type of
stuff when it's I don't know like for me
like what scares me is obviously like
most people I feel like is like realism
like give me a taste of like my own real
life and like a what if scenario I think
um it just didn't seem like yeah you
didn't know what you're doing but even
when they showed whatever lurking beasts
was like chasing you like it was so over
cause I put is that he's in like wow
just wasn't that scary to me yeah yeah
whatever that it was like a like a like
a naked woman with like a freaking like
split face something I've been quicker
almost from ya us I don't know in just
that mechanical own right I know just
that can get tired like it yeah I needed
more like it was kind of like I don't
know how much I would want to explore
that area mm-hmm no I got a goal or job
do my own yeah it's just a little early
though because we don't know what the
goal is so it's it's not that it's a no
or anything I think it looks really
intriguing I just want to know what
we're doing but you know it's so funny
it was like that's kind of not fair
considering how little I know about
routine but I can't wait to explore that
space I know they're gonna give me a
reason to go but I don't really know
much more about that either besides
exploring a very creepy space that's
probably gonna harm you yeah I mean I
guess routine at least had you know
narrative somewhere like you get you
guys know it's gonna game play too sure
um I just wanted to know what yeah I
want to know more about this hellscape
mm-hmm tell me what is this place tell
me much about this hell is there like a
real turn around here show me some good
deals on apartment overlooking the bay
in hell town blood bay I feel like I
could flip this place there's
it becomes a show on hgtv hello flipper
have flippers demon brothers take to the
framing of your house we're gonna bust
this wall that we're gonna make make a
nice blood fountain here I really tie
the room together my brother's acting
kind like a dick he like was trying to
take like 5050 when I totally did more
like the leg work on this leg deal so ok
you said this pool was lagoon like I
don't think there's anything lagoon like
about this pool by lagoon you mean
littered with dead bodies employment um
and then the last game want to touch on
is narcosis marry you and I played a
demo back JC earlier this year yeah
super scary the first game from honor
code developer uh it's less horror
focused than I thought going into it
yeah it is worth bringing up though
because the atmosphere of it you're
underwater you scuba diving narcosis
being the sickness that you get when you
like it send too fast and there's stuff
you're breathing in the wrong stuff Oh
through your tanks uh and you start
hallucinating and in the game you're
hallucinating you go into this one room
and there's a bunch of like diving suits
on the other wall to dead end you turn
around the door that you came into was
gone you keep spinning a circle you're
in this enclosed room now I'm getting a
lot of sphere vibes yeah that's a great
thing to consider I think maybe that's
like a part of what was so scary about
it was there's multiple things to be
afraid of there's um the narcosis itself
so yourself you're hallucinating you're
being really weird there's the actual
legitimate fear that you're underwater
and you will not have enough resources
to survive there forever so you need to
get to the surface immediately and then
there's also imminent threats there's
underwater sea life well there's like
spiders like the underwater spiders crap
I don't know they look like spiders
they're horrible oh yeah weird and I
hate them and hit him with um also
squids the squids that have like that
one little claw in the center of their
being I don't want to get into it I
think you have a seahorse no you're
doing I see what ya know it's the claw
in the whole of their Center truth there
gal go max yes and in yoga max yeah what
do you have helper oh that's why I oh so
you're being like him oh yeah i think
that the wrong side work
it's got rows of razor-sharp teeth how
are we supposed to all anyway it's gross
and the point is is there's imminent
threats and then there's threats on the
far horizon and there's more than enough
to upset you so it has a little bit more
I have to go back again to Selma it's
got that vibe because it has walking sim
elements to it right you like constantly
as you walk there is a voice that is you
like your head thinking and speaking to
yourself in your own head and your kind
of processing what's happened to you
what's going on and what happened in
your life before this that got you to
this place so there's like a lot to
uncover in terms of like the story and
what's going on but then oh man there's
jumpscares without a doubt like anytime
like a squid comes out of nowhere or
you're like running out of oxygen tanks
all the time or you you know you're
turning around and all of a sudden
you're in a completely different space
than you thought you were I was like in
a cave and like all of a sudden it was
like [ __ ] clock down there and is
like all right I'm hallucinating now and
it's just like this [ __ ] really messes
with you I think it's a really
interesting game also it's in VR I don't
think I mentioned that but the VR aspect
of it is also just mind-blowing because
you can hear all the water around you
and it's just very immersive and
upsetting uh it's funny I was looking at
that video and I stumbled upon you guys
did a piece on that having your BR
experience with it how you guys
described it like was actually we're
like really convincing and and happy to
hear that s prom with like sit down
games with walking in VR is that you
know you're kind of battling your brain
is like two different forms of look if
you have a control in your hand it's
like sometimes you just and resident
evil the demo we did it was kind of the
same way but it still worked because
you're doing kind of like fine-tuning
with your head and doing more the like
overall like main 360 looking with the
controller it's how I was playing at
least but this one you guys sold me on
like how the mechanic of like your your
suit is one entity of movement and then
the rest is you in a body almost like
the equivalent to why I think last games
where cockpit games driving you play
adrift no I didn't review that earlier
Syria it's kind of like narcosis in
space you're right derelict space ration
that blew up at some point or no it's
that it lends itself to VR because
instead of like when you're walking you
feel like you should have that walking
feel but when you're in when you're in a
cockpit or when you're in a suit like
this one you use Jet Propulsion to like
move you through the water you're like
this makes sense for why I feel floaty
and I don't feel the steps of movement
that makes more sense so there's less
there's more immersion it kind of just
like doesn't take you out of the game as
easily they should just make a game
where you put earplugs in and someone
like trickles dirt on your face and but
you're getting buried alive in the game
oh he's not moving you're just lying
there that'd be fun for like six hours
you beat the game if you can sit a
little lie still for 17 hours or it's
like how long can you scratch and tear
the wood on the coffin without you know
like before your arms get tired yeah
maybe a good workout game they should
put that unlike like I'm some kinda like
workout training you start singing your
favorite song to maintain your sanity
right uh yeah that'd be sick that'd be
tight we should develop the argues not
be awful uh I can run the gamut of
upcoming horror games Mary's giving me
the wrap-up ooh thing canada which she
does a lot more more recently ah cool so
yeah those kind of we just ran through a
bunch of ones that are either apparently
some are coming out December of next
year so don't keep an eye out for System
Shock remastered anytime soon although
there's a demo you put that and then a
lot of these in our early access I can't
wanna go play hello neighbor today
killing floor to at least in a week as
of this episode publishing yeah I'm
excited for all these Rob you gonna get
into more horror games now yeah hello
neighbor hello neighbor looks pretty
insane a lot of these games I am excited
to see streams of like Weatherby you
guys are myself like in general streams
they sound like they do you watch dreams
of yourself often know what I meant by
that is like me streaming it seems like
it could be fun yeah all around it's a
cool live experience married you watch
streams of yourself a lot yeah you
archive it and then just like but
dissect it right afterward yeah blinks
less here right I say that as someone
who blinks a lot he doesn't blink
he's got like a film in between his
eyelids in his eyes and thank you for
the [ __ ] wrap-up second luckily uh
don't see it cool cut away from it damn
it that's Rob anyway cool so as always
thanks for bringing us thanks for coming
and hanging out for watching on YouTube
and gamespot thanks for watching us is
our third video episode if you're on
iTunes thank you for listening as always
you can email us at dead air at gamespot
com you can tweet at us Rob handlery
Mike mihari marrakesh questions
suggestions concerns uh yeah give us a
review and itunes if you want and that
helps us out and of course like i said
we have a lot more resonable 7 stuff
coming up in the coming weeks which i'm
pretty excited about i will not be here
next week if you do an episode Mary in
my absence but I'm playing forward to
coming back from a trip I'm going on to
talk more about mystery stuff that we
can't talk about right now sure anyway
we will see you on it